northern ireland's hospitals are under
pressure today they were running at 106
occupancy and with winter looming
they've now asked the army to help the
minister for health has requested 100
medics to be sent over to support
exhausted staff
so they come train they come well
equipped they come well briefed and they
and they merge well with our work and
their staff as well because this is
really about not just the assistance
that we need and supporting our patients
but it's also to show our staff that
we're we're seeing what else we can do
to give them the support that they
currently need
[Applause]
no official decision has yet been made
on where the military medics will be
deployed to although we understand
they'll be sent here to the ulster
hospital as well as belfast city
hospital so why are they needed in the
first place well you only have to take a
look at the situation at northern
ireland's only dedicated children's
hospital
here the clinical director says it's
busier than he's seen it in 25 years of
practice and the worst is yet to come so
this is going to be a long difficult
winter and and the fact that we're
already in september and seeing those
high numbers is very worrying what we're
seeing now is that the normal winter
viruses that come along in october
november december are coming forward
quicker and bigger numbers and more
force because children don't have that
immunity that they would have had before
northern ireland is not alone in
scotland the government has also asked
for the military to help with the
intense challenges faced by the
ambulance service i apologize
unreservedly to anyone who has suffered
or who is suffering unacceptably long
waits a number of additional actions are
currently under active consideration i'm
happy to summarize these in further
exchanges but i can confirm
now that this includes consideration of
seeking
targeted military assistance to help
deal with short-term pressure points at
such military assistance is already
being provided to ambulance services in
england
as health authorities across the uk
prepare for military help frontline
staff like carl are urging the public to
only attend hospital if it's really
necessary
stephen murphy sky news in belfast